someone put on a fake tan over her last
time she shot a video do you call
brand-new character that gets introduced
for the first time in the reprisal of
full house fuller house a fake Tanner hi
guys my name is grace Helbig no no you
know your life is different now
Halloween is a time for socks it's at
one night of the year where anyone
regardless of race gender or religion
gets to tap in to their inner skank I've
seen some videos on YouTube where boys
try on sexy girl Halloween costumes and
I thought it's my turn now I'm gonna try
on sexy boy Halloween costume cuz they
exist and they are a lot I went on
Amazon a while ago slightly inebriated I
bought a bunch of sexy boy Halloween
costumes and I'm gonna try them on right
now because this is why the internet was
made I don't remember what costumes I
bought and I do remember thinking oh god
how am I gonna try this on on camera so
subscribe this youtube channel if you
haven't already it's what you're about
to see you probably cannot unsee it
vaguely remember a sexy firefighter all
right our first costume
is no cat stuff it's the only one I
could remember that I bought oh my god
shorts and braces I think they mean
suspenders this man's not smiling with
teeth so I can't tell if they mean teeth
braces but that would be hilarious no
offense but this seems a little
dangerous to be a firefighter and to run
into a burning building without a shirt
on and to run in wearing a material that
looks like the most flammable material
of all materials but this man's the fire
chief says his helmet I don't think it
comes with the helmet you just come to
Schwartz embraces but the good thing is
we know he's a professional because the
badge for Fire Department is directly
over at his wiener let's try this on
okay you're probably like grace how are
you gonna get around not showing your
tits on camera instant boy body let's
become hot stuff oh it's made out of the
material that beach balls are made out
of Oh No
we are the fire chief take us seriously
we worked hard to get to this position
our dad is proud of us this is as small
as this is thunders go oh no something
not right there we go elephantitis whoa
am i hot stuff yeah I mean this is
pretty identical ladies ladies you don't
datong where the fire is I know where it
is in my pants I have chlamydia we're
gonna need a hose for this fire and I
got a big one in my pants my balls are
swollen cuz I have chlamydia I have a
pole you can slide down
I had to install pole into my home
because my balls are something I
couldn't use my stairs anymore to exit
my home my father's so big because I got
chlamydia okay let's look at the next
sexy male costume Oh jailbait and oh
it's the same model
wow what a photo shoot day this must
have been I hope you got some good grams
out of it I see the theme and the way
the costumes are designed this is a
mankini and handcuffs
will it kini oh man apparently and the
good thing is I got this in a large the
other good thing is that we know he
should be in jail because it says guilty
directly over his wiener but the fun
thing that this is this one actually
comes with an cops it comes with the
accessory that it's advertising in the
picture that's become sexy jailbait Oh
Oh God
what what is this what Baby Bjorn what
is this wow that's gonna fit perfectly
you'll see in the front guilty in the
back how does this fit surprisingly
better wait a minute there we go
oh this is just pure sex oh these go
here there's a little hook for Oh cuz
this is how all prisoners in jail where
their handcuffs by their side holding
the keys I look so good in this costume
I know tonight I'm gonna get in mates
well a lot of people like playing World
of Warcraft but I'm more of a freecell
man myself
sale is what I call my butthole in my
prison they say if you do the crime you
got to do the time time is what I call
my bubble time for the next one also
sorry if the lighting is all over the
place I'm setting and resetting Wow Oh
sexy cowboy item hi cowboy contains
waistcoat chaps and scarf this guy's
rocking a killer handlebar moustache and
it doesn't come with it no chaps are
always a great time I've never tried
chaps on that I remember like I just
keep taping a bunch of airplane travel
pillows to my chest so sexy oh this is
our waistcoat I guess it's a waste of a
coat just the less it barely fits over
my muscles I might beat you ripped for
this costume that'd be cool
I'm a god of sex Japs oh my gosh what
where how do you do you
this feels confusing and weird like to
brown condoms for your legs get in and I
get jean shorts come on be a sexy male
cowboy whoa wait a minute
yeah there we go you better be careful
partner you nah gonna have to have a
shootout wieners I caught my wiener
Clint Eastwood cuz when I get a boner
curves to the right I'm only into
outlaws then I that closeted laws I
don't know why I'm making so many gay
jokes the costume teachers taking me
over and I feel really comfortable Hey
two left so let's see which do I have
left
oh we got a hot Scottie they have given
me two ways to wear this more
conservative way and then the hot Scotty
way down here without the shirt or the
pant oh this is intended for adult use
only age grade 14 plus please dear God
don't let there be any fourteen-year-old
boys wearing a hot Scottie this
Halloween Jesus Christ this bag is not a
toy that's the warning you want to give
about this costume this includes kilt
with attached sash Oh
hats belt with bag pair of socks garters
pants insured are not included god damn
it alright we'll put this on a second
let's see what the last one is
well genie in the lamp can you see that
genie in the lamp rub me I mean he
seemed so pleased with himself like it
makes me think that this guy created
this costume and just convinced this
company to take his photo and sell it
and they're like we're never gonna sell
one and then I bought one and they were
like well Frank you proved us wrong
includes best best lamp and cuffs thank
God it includes that lamp these are both
really great but I think I'm just gonna
try on genie in the lamp because I'm
running out of a card space here and I'm
sure you guys are sick of this video
concept right now but let's try on genie
in the lamp rub me this is not sexy at
all this is gross I mean with Aladdin
coming out soon this costume might be
very appropriate timing was also this
costume is just wholly inappropriate
that's their backs gonna be bad and then
the piece de resistance piece I would
most like to resist we did it Wow
I don't even want to make any jokes
about this I think this has enough on
its own
quick reminder I went to college weak
reminder my parents watch my videos
what's up dad if you weren't already so
confused about what I do for a living
welcome to this new career path I've
never looked better
I don't know I don't I don't know I I
told you that you would see things that
you cannot unsee and I am just so sorry
I think this concludes this video this
is a good time to stop I mean probably
should have stopped long before this
became a thing but hey better late than
never I don't think that's true never
would have been better that's it for
trying on sexy male Halloween costumes
hopefully this inspires you to get a
good Halloween costume go and think hard
on it and card on it if you guys like
this video subscribe to this YouTube
channel I'm making this Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometimes and click the phone
notifications so you get notified when
stuff like this happens leave a comment
down below which of these sexy male
costumes was your favorite I will see
you guys once I gain enough dignity to
forget this
and I don't know know if that ain't a
metaphor